you know what i'm going to be forced to
do archie
i'm being forced to go outside this
house if you don't want to do that
you know what that means don't you i
haven't been outside this house in seven
years
fresh air kills me the traffic drives me
crazy i live here alone with my beer and
my orchids in my work
ah where do i go now why do you have to
go anyplace
archie you are a victim of the nomadic
instincts of the tribal days
in this 20th century it's a waste of
time to go out
if you want to talk to somebody you pick
up a telephone if you want to find out
what's going on in the world
you read a newspaper if you want to
listen to find music
you tune in your radio and the symphony
concert if you want sunlight to turn on
the ultraviolet ray
if it's a hot day and you want to be
cool press a button and turn on a fan
if you're foolish enough to to believe
in exercise
you can always ride a mechanical horse
food meat and drink are brought to your
door
you can even buy your clothes by mail
look at those fools the streets are
always crowded with people
hopping back and forth back and forth
tiring themselves
rushing to nowhere